[Music]
in Turkey trap news I'm submitted by the
holidays my favorite time of year I love
it this job you know the holidays after
Thanksgiving it's like Thanksgiving
hurry up holidays is plural [ __ ] I
count I count Thanksgiving it's my nice
gaming second Halloween the beginning
the holidays ass too far too far to
stretch I like Halloween what I call it
like as part of all I feel like when you
enter hallow Halloween zone it's like
you're like you're entering the holiday
season people dress things up different
all year long like your house looks the
same right right and all of a sudden
Halloween comes you're like with spooky
time yeah oh it's brown leaf time and it
oh it's no time like this there's a
theme all the time I don't know why I
mean how Christmas is coming into stores
like in October why did let Halloween
have its moment in if I could I would
have a Christmas radio station
year-round Wow my friends and I used to
always have a Christmas party in the
summer because we would miss it so we'd
play Christmas music like all month long
and then have the party no cabbage trip
anyways anyways just weird that it
starts in October have a trip a man
killed by his booby trap rigged in his
own home on Thanksgiving Feliz a man
rigged his own booby traps about the
holidays it was killed Thanksgiving
night by a booby trap that he had
apparently rigged in his home officials
say it was Ronald Cyr of Van Buren Maine
he called 9-1-1 after he was shot by his
own self made his home security device
and was taken to the hospital I shot
myself how is it for intruders yeah so
because of the title the way you said
overtly I was like it was a turkey
trapping so the white wolf needs a
[ __ ] article yeah now soon bring it
all the way back there but so excited I
was like let's talk about Leif Leif
times hop shooting turkeys it sounded
crazy so he basically had rigged his
front door so that if someone tried to
like enter the front door a handgun
would shoot them
isn't like that like I want that home
alone [ __ ] with all this yeah pretty
much
good stories about this because I think
there's a story in California where some
dude was getting his garage broken into
all the time so he [ __ ] rigged a
shotgun I heard about that job of it he
got I don't think it went off but like
one of his neighbors saw that he did it
and report it to the police cuz that's
you know I think that's fair and
probably shouldn't booby-trapped your
house you know cuz what are the two
different shotgun shells you suppose
ever you have a book shot and what's the
other well they they just come in they
come in different sizes so you can go
it's it's mostly the size of the ball so
you either have a bunch of little
pellets or bb's yeah and those go from
like small little birdshot all webs like
like double odd book which are like big
ol like larger marbled kind of things
and then you also have slugs like deer
slugs which are like big ol like huge
like rounds chocolate from up here
wouldn't just kill you anyway
yeah probably gonna kill you these
people never heard of like an alarm
system like did well that's not enough
it I don't know this guy this guy was
this is America now it was in America
you know he was filling the Christmas
season early and so he was watching like
he was watching home alone he's like he
got inspired you think I've got a kid
can do it I can do it do remember like
what he did it yeah Kevin McCallister
was literally in front of the dog trap
with the gun and shot Boyd in the face
he also put them on fire he lit them on
fire there okay and it was funny so
imagine if you did it in real life
yeah with a real gun actually died
imagine that Darwinism yeah this guy
died which is unfortunate okay yeah you
saw I was killed so that's that's kind
of sad part we know no but he called the
cause yeah but he used to come to his
injuries a probably he had a slow
painful death
yeah he's like this was a bad idea do
you imagine like rigging this whole
thing and like being like Oh me so craft
do you like do you ever like do [ __ ]
like that way like you go out of your
way to do something that does not make
sense than fires and then it backfires
and you go I deserve this
yeah yeah that has happened to me a lot
more like who mmm-hmm sure like maybe
you snap things too high and it falls on
you you know we like second things
got so far yeah died but in the moment
it falls on me I'm not gonna be mad
about I just like I deserve you broke
your heart if you broke your arm again I
think you'd be kind of mad that's true
and you were you definitely kind of
deserve that but yeah apparently this
this happens frequently other than just
people and like kill them other time I
mentioned in California because a man in
southern Illinois was convicted last
year first-degree murder after a
booby-trap p-trap shock and he had rig
killed a man on his rural properties so
it's killed the correct manner the wrong
killed a man it just says a man I could
look into that story apparently not the
correct like someone who's trying to
hurt him yeah he got charged with land
first-degree murder first-degree murder
and aggravated battery if his
first-degree then he invited the guy
over yeah kill him
test something tell somebody real quick
well it worked
yeah I mean the way that I would see it
is that like yeah it's like a booby trap
I see why it's illegal to rig because
it's not like it's not like it's
necessarily your life is in danger in
that particular moment like it's you're
setting a trap for somebody who's coming
in but again one that's dangerous and
not really responsible and to like it's
your life net isn't necessarily in
danger just because someone's breaking
in you know are you happy about it when
it happened including the guy who killed
himself I was like yeah my [ __ ] so
complicated all these things did what it
was supposed to be really funny you know
like the Rube Goldberg inventions that
take forever to like do a simple thing
he's just watch he's like opens the door
and he like looks like I'm like a little
marble that's like falling all around
this house like a wine bottle all the
Agathe see all the gives breath he's
like come on just just pop sports
I've only wanted to know what it was
like to just like dig a hole and then
cover it damn Julie that dark dig a hole
you know hole and then put like a net
and then like put leaves on top oh yeah
just so that when people walk over it
they can't fall straight through it I've
done that before as a kid yeah I
remember I heard about like these traps
that you could make around like around
oh I did once before I remember digging
like a hole that was like a foot deep
and you put like a plastic bag over it
and then you cover it with like a light
dusting of dirt or with leaves or
whatever so that someone could just like
tripping what's inside that with some
time the whole [ __ ] sharpened bamboo
no I learned it from cartoons yeah well
those holes are too big to fit a whole
human being even as a kid I was too lazy
for that [ __ ] I was like I will make
their football yeah but that's that's
just kind of dangerous cuz I was and
then they break because you're like
falling you like stuff you're like twist
your ankle or whatever and they sue you
oh I wasn't gonna stay around for that
part you weren't gonna watch it happen
oh you're hard no I left
so you just booby-trapped the [ __ ]
[ __ ] is that arguably better or worse he
just lost interest imagine you like how
much Your Honor I was like what did you
do at the park today like walks away I'm
just saying I did just imagine it's like
the little shovel that you use at the
beach yeah what are you doing he never
brought full-size shovels you Beach I've
done that before oh good like shine
holes at the beach wait go ahead Andy
yeah yeah and you dig a little hold the
water you can peat it what home sorry my
beach days are very different yeah let's
rewind a little bit
what's this people that you're touchy
about now let's totally pee in the water
yeah where no one would see it it was
pretty deep nose it is absolutely step
in it several feet down until you
[ __ ] covered it with a plastic oh my
god yeah cuz I'm just I'm also imagining
else is just it's like describing all
this and then like we like zoom out from
his head and he's like yeah yeah he
looks at you used here like a whimper
like stop one fun pee story at the beach
how many of these do you got right I've
had a very exciting childhood you pee on
a lot of things no off at the beach also
in the sand
I never one time I need to pee and I was
like I don't know where the bathrooms
are because we weren't in that section
of the beach where you can conveniently
get to the bathroom ah so dug a hole
where I laid down on top of and I just I
just peed in the hole this looks dude
I'm like oh yeah nothing's going on so
you're like post on the front you put on
the front you got a hole there you pee
out I mean you're the beach you have a
sandy dick you're like a really sandy do
pee and you get really warm yeah that's
my best feeling
like that sanding your penis is much
better you wash it off guys just give
this step where you get sand in your
penis wouldn't the sad scratch up your
penis and I dug a hole was it wet sand
or dry sand when your penis was in it
medium it wasn't really wet but it was
like it was wet after four it was a good
not working make a pose was it warmly
was like that nice therapeutics and it
was like a Masai I'm so covered no knows
I'm peeing again walking by the kid I
had all our free green so I would take
the bus to the beach oh oh yeah you can
just repeat yeah I didn't know one
Johnny it was like of what 20 minute bus
ride legend says you still find that
hole somewhere honey I'm never gonna
look at kids the same way you sick [ __ ]
why is peeing in the water and you
feelin it better I like the better
because it'll get washed away with all
the water whatever you pick the whole
you being you know it's it stays there
deep it's a deep hole guys that's why my
pick wasn't on the sand I think it's
more of the secrecy of like doing the
deed like in this place where you can
just kind of like no one knows you're
doing it as opposed to like just laying
down this in it's a really funny picture
no one knows I'm just laying there it's
really obvious in my head no it's not my
ass wasn't exposed guys I wasn't laying
that with chicks open it's so much
funnier if you were
I'm a picture
[Music]